risk take are drawn to risk
entrepreneurial Cowboys have very little
patience with the puritanical mindset
which is not to take risks work hard
every day save small amounts increment
incrementally and build up your your
fortune in that manner whereas and that
the Puritans have very little patience
for risk-taking Cowboys who are willing
to gamble most or all of their future
for example I'm heading out across a
2,000 mile stretch of continent that
hasn't been explored you what what both
sides need to appreciate is that the
American experience is a combination of
the entrepreneurial cowboy and the
Puritan work ethic and that the two
strains have made us who we are as a
country and that in poker you need to
make risks you need to put money in the
pot in a speculative way to in order to
have any hope of doubling your money in
that particular hand and yet you also
have to have you also have to deploy
what might be called Puritan money
management skills conservatives and
patience waiting for a good hand so that
an effective poker player typically
involves start again
playing poker effectively typically
involves both entrepreneurial
risk-taking and a Puritan conservatism
with and bankroll management skills
well I'm
Americans have an immigrant specific
genotype which is to say that to only
two percent of the people of the
populations that fit into this country
accepting the Native Americans and the
slaves came over here and those that two
percent of the immigrant population is
much more likely to take risks they tend
to be smarter quicker decision makers
and more intelligent and and more
interested in making taking large risks
in order to dramatically improve their
lives when you combine that with the
fact that this is the first free market
capitalist society with the fact that
money is the language of poker it's it's
the only means by which you can keep
score it's the way that you leverage
your hand against often what our better
hands are often better hands and you as
Walter Matthau put it poker exemplifies
the worst aspects of capitalism which
have made our country so great I think
it's a wonderfully succinctly the
relationship between the American spirit
and the poker mentality